The least common multiple of X plus 2 and 2x minus 4 is just their product, X
plus 2 times X minus 4. In order to make our first fraction have that
denominator, we need to multiply it by 2x minus over 2x minus 4. And we need to
multiply by the second fraction to have achieve the same end goal by X plus 2
over X plus 2. Once I've written out what each of these fractions is With the
same denominator, I can think about how to combine the numerators. We'll be able
to just add the numerators together since they have the same denominator. So,
when we do that, the numerators going to be 2X minus 4 minus 3 times X plus 2.
So, I'll simplify that and then put it in the fraction, this is just going to
save me some space. This simplifies to negative X minus 10. Or if I want to pull
out a factor of negative 1, negative in parentheses x plus 10. Then I can write
the negative sign outside of the entire fraction and put x plus 10 as the
numerator.